michelle bachelet's long-awaited report
is a damning indictment of china's
treatment of the uyghur population it
found that uyghurs and other mostly
muslim groups held in detention camps
have been subjected to torture including
forced medical treatment and sexual and
gender-based violence
bachelet's report was commissioned more
than three years ago and was due to be
published last year it was finally
released 30 minutes before her term as
u.n human rights chief ended obviously
there
there's pressure from the chinese
government on the u.n system but it's
the
high commissioner's job to investigate
human rights crimes around the world
including china so we're very glad to
see at least the report report is out
obviously we wish it was
released
sooner
china has condemned the report it says
its policies in xinjiang fight what it
calls terrorism and provide uighurs with
better economic opportunities we all
know
so well that
the so-called xinjiang issue
is completely
is a completely fabricated lie out of
political
motivations and
its purpose definitely
is to undermine china's
stability
and to obstruct china's development
in the past bachelets face criticism for
not being forthright about the
persecution of the uyga community
her visit to china in may was widely
condemned as a whitewash with the u.s
state department calling it a mistake
human rights groups say her report is
better late than never this is a
blueprint really for member states
especially those
who sit on the human rights council to a
doctor resolution that creates an
independent and international mechanism
so that you can start investigating
these crimes and you can start
identifying the perpetrators and
prosecuting those perpetrators
this is the latest of many reports
detailing human rights abuses against
uyghurs
but this one carries the weight of the
un and those campaigning for justice
hope it'll mark a turning point victoria
gatenbee al jazeera